I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi everyone. Good morning.
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演过《办公室》（The Office），而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来这档终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”哦。大家好。大家早安。
All right, we're still saying goodbye to Michael. I know. It's goodbye, Michael, part two. This is the real deal, goodbye. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it.
好啦，我们还是要向迈克（Michael）告别。我知道。这是“再见，迈克”第二集。这才是动真格的告别。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。
This is the it. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it. This is the it.
这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。这就是那个时刻。
This is the it. Yeah. We had the funny last week and now we're going to get into a lot of crying. Oh, man. Once again, season seven, episode 22, written by Greg Daniels and directed by Paul Feig. You know, last week we didn't do a summary. No summary needed. No.
这就是那个时刻。没错。我们上周经历了搞笑，现在我们要开始大哭一场了。天呐。再说一遍，第七季第 22 集，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）编剧，保罗·费格（Paul Feig）导演。你知道的，上周我们没有做总结。根本不需要总结。没错。
It's goodbye, Michael. I'm not summing anything up again. That's right. sticking with this. And this week we are back again with Greg for the second part. But Jenna, did you have any fast facts? I don't have any fast facts, but I have a fun fact.
这就是“再见，迈克”。我可不再做什么总结了。没错，就这么定了。而这周我们又请回了格雷格来聊第二部分。不过珍娜，你有什么速记快讯吗？我没有什么速记快讯，但我有一个趣闻。
I'll take a fun fact. All right, here's the fun fact. This episode aired on April 28th, 2011, and its broadcast in the United States was interrupted in several places because of William and Kate's royal wedding. They were married on Kate Middleton and Prince William. Yes, yes.
那我要听趣闻。好，趣闻是这样的。这一集于 2011 年 4 月 28 日播出，由于威廉（William）和凯特（Kate）的皇家婚礼，它在美利坚合众国的几个地方的播出被打断了。他们是在凯特·米德尔顿（Kate Middleton）和威廉王子大婚那天结婚的。没错，没错。
Like you're like some other William and Kate. Yeah, like who else is having a royal wedding named William? That's preempting television. Yes, yes, okay. So they were married on April 29th, but with the time change, it was a conflict. And so for example, in Chicago, the NBC affiliate posted a notice on their website
听起来好像还有别的什么威廉和凯特似的。对啊，还有谁办皇家婚礼叫威廉的？这都在抢占电视播出时段。没错，没错，好吧。所以他们是在 4 月 29 日结婚的，但由于时差关系，这就起冲突了。比如说，在芝加哥，全国广播公司（NBC）的分支机构在他们的网站上发布了一条通知
that said this, due to live coverage of the royal wedding, tonight's regularly scheduled lineup of Community the Office, Parks and Recreation, 30 Rock and Outsourced will be seen on Sunday, starting at 7 p.m. Oh, no way. So you still got the episode. You just got it a few days later. Yeah.
上面写着：由于对皇家婚礼的现场直播，今晚按计划播出的《废柴联盟》（Community）、《办公室》、《公园与游憩》（Parks and Recreation）、《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）以及《外包公司》（Outsourced）将改在周日晚上 7 点开始播出。哦，不会吧。所以你还是看到了这一集。只是晚了几天才看到。对啊。
I feel like I would be so mad if I was in Chicago. It's goodbye, Michael. Yeah, that's one of your favorite shows. And then everybody else got to see it on Thursday and you have to wait till Sunday. Yeah, and this was also before you could just go online and see like little clips of the wedding.
我要是在芝加哥，我肯定会气死。那是“再见，迈克”啊。对啊，那是你最喜欢的节目之一。然后所有人都在周四看到了，而你却得等到周日。对啊，而且这还是在你不能直接上网看婚礼小片段的年代。
I know. Like maybe you don't have to watch the whole shebang. Well, we learned that now. Yeah. Now we just watch the clips. Yeah. Although I did watch their wedding. You watched the wedding instead of our show?
我知道。就好像你其实不用看整个全过程一样。好吧，我们现在知道了。对啊。现在我们只看小片段。对啊。虽然我确实看了他们的婚礼。你看了婚礼而不是我们的节目？
No, I got to watch both. Do you have a little side-by-side setup? No. You're watching William and Kate? Oh, no, no, no. You're watching Michael Check Names off his list? No, I got to watch both. I got to sit and have my moment with both.
不，两个我都看了。你弄了个分屏同时观看吗？没有。你在看威廉和凯特？哦，不，不，不。你在看迈克从他的名单上划掉名字？不，两个我都看了。我坐下来，属于我的两个我都看了。
But you know, I mean, I love a wedding. I'll watch any wedding. Invite me to your wedding. I love weddings. People do invite us to their weddings. I know. I know this is gonna be our retirement, Angela. It's going to people's weddings.
不过你知道的，我是说，我喜欢婚礼。任何婚礼我都看。邀请我去参加你的婚礼吧。我喜欢婚礼。人们确实会邀请我们去参加他们的婚礼。我知道。我知道这会是我们的退休生活，安吉拉。就是去参加别人的婚礼。
Popping up at people's weddings. Well, I have a fun fact. What's your fun fact? I've got some awesome Office Ladies news. Mm-hmm. Are you ready for it? I know it. Tell them.
突然出现在别人的婚礼上。好吧，我有一个趣闻。你的趣闻是什么？我有一些关于“办公室女士”的超棒消息。嗯哼。准备好了吗？我知道是什么。告诉他们吧。
Next week on Office Ladies, we have Steve Carell. Yes! He's gonna be in the studio with us. It is such an amazing interview. We had so much fun talking to him. I can't wait for you guys to hear it. We've had a really exciting 2023 so far. Big episodes, big guests, new studio.
下周的“办公室女士”，我们请到了史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）。耶！他将和我们一起在录音室里。这是一场太棒的访谈了。和他聊天我们度过了非常开快的时光。我迫不及待想让你们听听了。到目前为止，我们的 2023 年过得非常令人兴奋。重磅剧集、重量级嘉宾、全新录音室。
Very spicy stuff, guys. Spicy? I don't know. We're shaking it up. Shaking it up. Shaking it up. Do you remember Shake and Bake? Did you ever shake and bake?
非常劲爆的内容哦，伙计们。劲爆？我不知道。我们在搞点新花样。搞点新花样。搞点新花样。你还记得 Shake and Bake 裹粉吗？你用过 Shake and Bake 吗？
Are you kidding? Is that still around? Could I shake and bake today if I wanted? I'd be so excited. I love a shake and bake. I'm gonna look for it in the store. All right, listen. Let's take a quick break and then we'll be back
你在开玩笑吗？现在还有这东西吗？如果我现在想用 Shake and Bake，还能买到吗？我会超级兴奋的。我可太喜欢 Shake and Bake 了。我要去店里找找看。好了，听着。我们稍作休息，马上回来
to break down the rest of Goodbye Michael with Greg Daniels. Get your tissues. ["Goodbye Michael"] Well, here we all are back for part two. Greg, we left off with Michael going into Darrell's office to give Darrell the only copy of his book, Somehow I Manage.
和格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起剖析“再见，迈克”的剩余部分。准备好纸巾吧。["再见，迈克"] 好吧，我们大家都回来继续第二部分了。格雷格，我们刚才讲到迈克走进达瑞尔（Darrell）的办公室，把他的书《我如何管理》的唯一副本交给了达瑞尔。
Here is my question for you. Will you please write the book Somehow I Manage by Michael Scott and publish it? I want to read this book that just the chapter on gum alone was amazing. I'm trying to remember what the whole story was about that book because that was another one of those things that was floating around on our corkboard forever
我有个问题想问你。你愿意写一本迈克·斯科特写的《我如何管理》并把它出版吗？我想读读这本书，光是关于口香糖的那一章就太精彩了。我一直在努力回想关于那本书的整个故事是怎么回事，因为那是另一个永远在我们编剧室的软木板上飘来飘去的东西
in the writer's room. It was mentioned in Date Night. Yeah. He's trying to impress Donna. Yeah, but I actually think it had an existence as a book project. Really? Yeah.
它在《约会之夜》（Date Night）里被提到过。对啊。他试图给唐娜（Donna）留下好印象。对啊，但我其实觉得它作为这个图书项目是真实存在过的。真的吗？对啊。
I'm kind of thinking maybe BJ was gonna write it or something like that at one point. I just need it to be written. I know, right? That would be a terrific piece of it. What is that? That's just unclaimed money sitting on a shelf. I was really curious if there was any version
我有点觉得，也许 BJ（BJ Novak）一度打算写它或者别的什么。我只是需要它被写出来。我知道，对吧？那将是一个了不起的部分。那是什么？那只是一笔放在架子上没人认领的钱。我真的很想知道外面有没有任何版本
of a book with that name out there. And when I Googled it, I did find a book on Amazon and it's got a photo of Michael Scott on the cover and he's in like a suit. It's got like a little gold sticker that says Scranton Times bestseller. And then when you go to see what the book is about, it says this.
顶着这个名字的书。当我用谷歌搜索时，我确实在亚马逊上找到了一本书，它的封面上有迈克·斯科特的照片，他穿着西装之类的。上面还有一个金色的小贴纸，上面写着“斯克兰顿时代畅销书”。然后当你去查看这本书是关于什么的，上面写了这些。
It's made me laugh. This is a blank ruled notebook. It offers 100 pages of created space for all the brilliant ideas and doodles that you will likely create during your business meetings. Yeah, so obviously BJ never turned in his manuscript. I guess not. You can buy a blank one.
这把我逗笑了。这是一本空白的带横线笔记本。它为你在商务会议期间可能产生的的所有绝妙想法和涂鸦提供了 100 页的创作空间。是的，所以显然 BJ 从未交出他的手稿。我想是的。你可以买一本空白的。
Michael's final wish is to get to operate the Baylor. Another callback? Yep. And I love that Darrell is like, no. And then right away, it gets to Michael in the warehouse and he's like, so Darrell said I could use the Baylor and they're like, nope, exactly. And then another callback to basketball.
迈克的最后愿望是去操作打包机。又一个呼应？没错。我喜欢达瑞尔说：不行。然后紧接着，镜头切到仓库里的迈克，他说：所以达瑞尔说我可以用打包机，他们就说：不行，就是这样。然后又是对篮球的呼应。
He's going to catch them all on the flippity flip and he's trying to toss the basketball into the hoop over his shoulder from behind. Kelsey H. from Olympia, Washington loves this multiple attempts to catch people on the flippity flip. Wanted to know if that was scripted, that he would have to do it over and over and over again. It was scripted, I went to the script.
他要在空中飞人那一刻接住他们，他正试图从后面越过肩膀把篮球扔进篮筐。来自华盛顿州奥林匹亚的凯尔西·H（Kelsey H.）非常喜欢这种多次试图在空中飞人那一刻抓住人们的桥段。想知道这是否是剧本写好的，他得一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地做这件事。这是剧本写好的，我去查了剧本。
You said he tries to do this over and over and over again and you explain how it should be cut together. Well, it makes sense. I mean, there's no way he would have sunk it on one attempt. And the first one, right. I mean, the thing that I had that would have been amazing. In re-watching it, the thing I liked best was the lighting change.
你说他试图一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地做这件事，并且你解释了它应该如何剪辑在一起。好吧，这说得通。我是说，他根本不可能一次就投进。而且第一次，没错。我是说，我最喜欢的事情是——那会很了不起。在重看的时候，我最喜欢的变化是灯光的变化。
Yeah, to show the passage of time. It's like the sun is setting. He's been at it for four hours. Well, we have another callback within the scene because flippity flip was first said in the episode Murder. Oh, yes. He says to David Wallace, the secretary. All right, catch you on the flippity flip.
对，为了展现时间的流逝。就像太阳在下山。他已经搞了四个小时了。好吧，我们在这一场戏里还有另一个呼应，因为“空中飞人”这个词最早是在《谋杀》（Murder）那一集里说的。哦，是的。他对秘书大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）说。好了，空中飞人时见。
Was that in the script too, flippity flip? Yes, yeah. Yeah, it was. Nice. Andy and D'Angelo are out on their sales call now. D'Angelo is like wondering what their bid's going to be. And D'Angelo is trying to pump Andy up. He's trying to pump himself up.
这也是剧本里写的吗，空中飞人？是的，对。是的，是这样的。太棒了。安迪（Andy）和迪安杰洛（D'Angelo）现在出去拜访客户了。迪安杰洛在想他们的出价会是多少。迪安杰洛在试图给安迪打气。他在试图给自己打气。
And he goes, you know what we need to do? We need to go to an animal shelter. Annie Annie Shelto is what he says. Yes. And that can't have been in the script. That sounds like a complete Will Ferrell ad lib. I didn't check. Randy said that Will was really driving the car
然后他说，你知道我们需要做什么吗？我们需要去动物收容所。动物安妮收容所（Annie Shelto），这是他说的。是的。这不可能是剧本里的。听起来完全像是威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）的即兴发挥。我没有查。兰迪（Randy）说，威尔在整场车戏中真的在开车
during this whole car scene, that that was freestyle driving, and that Matt Stone and Paul Feig were in the back seat. We shot a lot of stuff in cars like that. And it's funny now, whenever I bring that up as a possibility on anything I'm working on, people look at me like that's the most dangerous and unprofessional thing anybody could ever do. So I don't know.
那是自由式驾驶，而且马特·斯通（Matt Stone）和保罗·费格坐在后座上。我们在这样的车里拍了很多东西。现在有趣的是，每当我把这作为我正在做的任何事情的一种可能性提出来时，人们看着我的眼神，就像这是任何人能做出的最危险、最不专业的事情一样。所以我不知道。
Fairly, that's not cool to make an actor drive and talk and think at the same time. Well, we will get to it. But do you remember when the character of Nellie is learning how to drive? I know this story. And Pam is going to help her with her driving lessons. Were you in the car together?
公平地说，让一个演员边开车、边说话、边思考，这可真不酷。好吧，我们会讲到这点的。但是你还记得内莉（Nellie）这个角色学开车的时候吗？我知道这个故事。而帕姆（Pam）要帮她上驾驶课。你们当时在同一辆车里吗？
We were in the car together, and they let Catherine Tate drive. That's an extra layer, because she's on the wrong side of the road for her. Catherine Tate didn't know how to drive. She didn't drive. I'll tell that story more in depth when we get there. Well, I think back to the fact that my character ran Moes off the road, we really did do this crazy driving stunt
我们在同一辆车里，他们让凯瑟琳·塔特（Catherine Tate）开车。这又加了一层难度，因为对她来说那是路的错误一侧。凯瑟琳·塔特当时根本不会开车。她不会开车。等我们讲到那里时，我会更深入地讲这个故事。好吧，回想一下我的角色把莫斯（Moe）挤出路的那个情节，我们确实做了一个疯狂的驾驶特技
where then I got out of the car and ran up and slapped him. But I pull into this cul-de-sac, and he'd go sideways. And I was driving my car. Yeah, well, it's weird. It's like for the documentary part of the show. I don't think it's unusual for a documentary to interview somebody driving a car. Yeah, true.
然后我从车里出来，跑过去打了他的耳光。但我把车开进这个死胡同里，而他侧着身子。而且是我自己在开车。是的，好吧，这很奇怪。就像是为了节目的纪录片部分。我觉得纪录片采访一个正在开车的人并不罕见。是的，确实。
But there's a lot of Hollywood rules. So now at Bays, it seems like they would tow that car. Or have a drone hovering outside of the car. Well, they find their Annie Annie shell tow. By the way, this is such a weird scene. So bizarre. And I don't get this distance from the show, unfortunately.
但是有很多好莱坞规则。所以现在在贝斯（Bays），他们似乎会把那辆车拖走。或者让一架无人机在车外盘旋。好吧，他们找到了他们的动物安妮收容所。顺便说一句，这真是一场奇怪的戏。太诡异了。不幸的是，我对这一集没有这种距离感。
I don't remember exactly everything that I put in. But my feeling is that I really like this scene, but it doesn't feel like I wrote it to myself. I don't know where it came from. It feels like a weird kind of a room build out. I wonder if this was another ad. Yeah, was this shot afterwards? I think that it was.
我不记得我确切放进去了什么。但我的感觉是，我真的很喜欢这场戏，但它感觉不像是写给自己的。我不知道它是从哪里来的。感觉像是编剧室里拼凑出来的一种奇怪的东西。我想知道这是否是另一个即兴。是的，这是事后补拍的吗？我想是的。
I asked Randy Cordray if we went to a real animal shelter to shoot this. And he said no, it was a fakie animal shelter. He said the exterior was just a building. And our graphics designer, Michael Beuth, made the sign. I have some fun info on the dog that they're passing back and forth in this scene. This is an animal actor named Wally,
我问过兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray），我们是不是去了一个真正的动物收容所拍这个。他说没有，那是个假的动物收容所。他说外景只是一栋建筑。我们的图形设计师迈尔斯·布思（Michael Beuth）制作了那个牌子。关于他们在这一场戏里传来传去的这只狗，我有一些有趣的信息。这是一只名叫沃利（Wally）的动物演员，
who was provided by Bob Dunn's Animal Services. Randy sent me the invoice for Wally's work on the show. How much Wally submitted an invoice for his time. What did Wally make this day? The total was $1,713. I found this invoice fascinating. Does the same thing just stunt work? Yes.
由鲍勃·邓恩动物服务公司（Bob Dunn's Animal Services）提供。兰迪给我发了沃利在这部剧中工作的账单。多少钱？沃利为他的时间提交了一张账单。沃利这一天赚了多少钱？总额是 1713 美元。我觉得这张账单太令人着迷了。特技工作也这样吗？是的。
Does he have a per diem? Here's the thing. He gets a prep day. So he charged us, the dog cost $225 for the prep day. And the trainer was $344. Then he charged us for a shoot day. And a trainer for a shoot day charged us for transportation. Cost us $200 to transport him.
他有每日津贴吗？事情是这样的。他有一个准备日。所以他向我们收费，这只狗的准备日费用是 225 美元。训练师是 344 美元。然后他收了我们拍摄日的费用。拍摄日的训练师向我们收取了交通费。花了 200 美元运送他。
Took a car, took a very nice, nice car. But my favorite was this little tidbit. We also had to pay for a backup dog. His name was Amos. Aw. So Amos came along, didn't get to work. And that's how you got to that total. That's another spin-off I want to see.
坐了一辆车，坐了一辆非常好的、非常好的车。但我最喜欢的是这个小八卦。我们还得为一只备用狗付钱。它的名字叫阿莫斯（Amos）。哦。所以阿莫斯也一起来了，却没有机会工作。这就是你算出那个总数的过程。这是另一个我想看的衍生剧。
It's the jealous Amos-Wally relationship. It's playing out behind the scenes. Well, there's a very important piece of information that comes out of the scene, which is we find out how D'Angelo was hired. Yeah. He basically was hired because he stopped someone from taking Joe's dog.
是嫉妒的阿莫斯和沃利的关系。它在幕后上演着。好吧，这场戏里透露出一个非常重要的信息，那就是我们发现了迪安杰洛是怎么被雇用的。对啊。他基本上被雇佣是因为他阻止了别人抢走乔（Jo）的狗。
Wow. That's how you became manager of a paper company. Well, the arc with Will Ferrell was so terrific and so useful and everything for the show to have this exciting guest star come in. But I think that people knew it wasn't forever. And some of the fun jokes in this episode are just these little hints that we're getting
哇。这就是你如何成为一家纸业公司经理的办法。好吧，与威尔·法瑞尔的剧情线太棒了，对整部剧来说也太有用了，能有这位令人兴奋的客串明星加入。但我认为人们知道这不是永久的。这一集里的一些搞笑笑话只是这些小小的暗示，让我们知道
that he is really not going to be a good manager. Or a long-term choice. Yeah. Next up, we have a scene between Michael and Aaron. And this is a wonderful callback to Secretary's Day. In fact, this whole scene takes place on the bench where they sat in Secretary's Day. I thought it was really sweet.
他真的不会成为一个好经理。或者说不是长期人选。好的，接下来，我们有迈克和艾琳（Erin）之间的一场戏。这是对“秘书节”的一个精彩呼应。事实上，整场戏都发生在他们在“秘书节”坐过的那张长椅上。我觉得这真的很甜蜜。
Yeah. Yeah, Michael says, you don't need a mom because you have me. Yeah. You have my number. Yeah. You can call me anytime. I'll be your dad. That's one of the relationships.
对啊。是的，迈克说，你不需要妈妈，因为你有我。对啊。你有我的电话。对啊。你随时都可以打电话给我。我会做你的爸爸。这是那种关系之一。
People always used to say about workplace ensembles that they turn into family shows. Even though the people aren't related, but they have variations on family relationships. Sure. Yeah. And this was a good opportunity for Michael to be a dad to somebody.
人们过去常说，关于职场群像剧，它们最终会变成家庭剧。尽管大家没有血缘关系，但他们有着各种家庭关系的变体。当然。是的。对迈克来说，这也是一个成为某人父亲的好机会。
I don't know who else he has more of a dad relationship with. Yeah. It's definitely Aaron. Yeah. And it's good advice. The other thing is, if you want to make somebody likeable, if they give good advice to somebody, that was one of the tricks that we used in season two.
我不知道他还和谁有更深厚的这种父女关系。对啊，绝对是艾琳。对啊。这也是很好的建议。另一件事是，如果你想让一个人讨人喜欢，如果他们给别人好建议，那是我们在第二季中使用的小把戏之一。
I wrote that into Booz Cruise. Try and, if you remember, the season two fall was all about giving Michael little things that people would root him, you know, would like him for. Right. And he gives that advice to Jim. Yeah, and he gives good advice to Jim. So that's another callback in a way.
我把它写进了《酒船巡游》（Booz Cruise）。试着，如果你还记得的话，第二季的秋季档全都是关于给迈克一些小细节，让观众会支持他，你知道的，会因此喜欢他。没错。他给吉姆（Jim）提出了那个建议。对啊，他给了吉姆很好的建议。所以从某种程度上说，这也是另一个呼应。
Yeah. This next scene, we're back in the bullpen. The camera starts on Aaron on the phone at reception. It pulls back to reveal Phyllis on a sales call. Michael hangs up Phyllis' sales call and tells her, just work on the mittens. I need the mittens by 4 PM. Yeah, he's kind of laying waste to the company,
是的。接下来的这场戏，我们回到了大办公区。镜头从前台正在打电话的艾琳开始。镜头拉开，露出正在进行销售通话的菲利斯（Phyllis）。迈克挂断了菲利斯的销售电话，告诉她：只要织好手套就行。我需要在下午 4 点前拿到手套。对啊，他在临走前把公司弄得一团糟，不是吗，对吧？
isn't he, on its way out, right? He's interrupting her sales call. Andy's blowing all their biggest clients. Yeah. Yeah. Well, at 21 minutes and 21 seconds, I noticed, Greg, that Aaron and Phyllis are holding their phones the exact same way.
他在打断她的销售电话。安迪把他们最大的客户全都搞砸了。对啊。好吧，在 21 分 21 秒时，我注意到，格雷格，艾琳和菲利斯拿电话的姿势完全一样。
Yes. And we have found out in this episode that Phyllis gave up a child. Yes. Right? That was in a talking head. And this comes right after Michael and Aaron have this moment where Michael says, you don't need a mom.
是的。而且我们在这一集中发现，菲利斯抛弃过一个孩子。是的。对吧？那是在单独访谈里说的。而这正好发生在迈克和艾琳有那个温馨时刻之后，迈克在那个时刻说：你不需要妈妈。
And now we cut to Phyllis and Aaron holding the phone the same way. Are you teasing out that Phyllis might be Aaron's mom? So I think so, because something like that would have been a card on the board. Long time before we were writing, we would have been assessing all of the different possible storylines.
现在我们切到菲利斯和艾琳用同样的方式拿电话。你是在暗示菲利斯可能是艾琳的妈妈吗？我想是的，因为像这样的事情会是板子上的卡片。在我们写作很久以前，我们就一直在评估所有不同的可能故事情节。
And when does that start to really come into play? I'm not sure exactly when it gets introduced, but there is that storyline of Aaron, who is being encouraged by Andy to kind of look for her birth parents. Yeah. Well, this is the first we learn that Phyllis had a child. That's the secret she thinks Michael's
而这到底是什么时候才真正开始发挥作用的？我不太确定它是什么时候被引入的，但确实有艾琳的那条故事线，她在安迪的鼓励下开始寻找她的亲生父母。对啊。好吧，这是我们第一次得知菲利斯曾经有个孩子。这就是她认为迈克
going to tell the bullpen. That's right. Yeah. That's a big drop of a piece of information there, yeah. It's very Phyllis, though. Phyllis really dropped some interesting info in her talking heads. Like you learned a lot about her in Bob Vance.
要在大办公区说出来的秘密。没错。对啊，那里爆出了一个很大的信息，是的。不过这很菲利斯。菲利斯真的在她的单独访谈里抛出了一些有趣的信息。就像你通过鲍勃·凡斯（Bob Vance）了解了很多关于她的事。
Oh my god, speaking of talking heads, can we talk about Rainn Wilson's performance in this talking head where he reads the letter of recommendation from Michael? Yeah. Just perfectly played. I made myself cry writing this. I was in a coffee bean, and I identify a little bit too much
哦，天哪，说到单独访谈，我们能聊聊雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）在这段单独访谈里的表演吗？他在里面读了迈克写的推荐信。对啊。简直演得完美。我写这段的时候自己都哭了。我当时在咖啡豆（Coffee Bean）咖啡馆，我可能
with Dwight, probably. But yeah, I thought this was a great talking head. And he was so good at it. He was so good at it. I love that last line. Oh, I love the pause that he takes. The turn, when he's mocking it, he realizes how good it is. Then there's the pause.
对德怀特（Dwight）有点过于感同身受了。但，是的，我觉得这是一段很棒的单独访谈。他演得太好了。他演得太好了。我喜欢最后那句台词。哦，我喜欢他停顿的那一下。当他在嘲弄这封信，然后意识到它写得有多好时，那个转变。接着是一次停顿。
And then the blah, blah, blah, just a bunch more stuff. Yeah. Yeah, when he says. It's very repetitive. Yeah, but then after that, he's like, when he gets to the point, as a sales executive, as a leader, as a man, and as a friend, he is of the highest kind quality and order supreme.
然后是“blablahblah，只是一堆更多的话”。对啊。是的，当他说。这太重复了。是的，但在这之后，他说：当他谈到重点时——作为一名销售主管，作为一名领导者，作为一名男人，以及作为一位朋友，他是最高品质和无上秩序的。
And then you see all the emotion. I was like, yes, give me goosebumps just when you read it. And then I loved the button about paintball. It was perfect. They really shot paintballs at each other. Yes, I was looking at the DVD notes. Another instance of the show, perhaps not following the most stringent.
然后你看到了所有的情绪。我当时就想：是的，读到这里让我起鸡皮疙瘩。然后我喜欢关于彩弹的那个包袱。太完美了。他们真的互相朝对方发射了彩弹。是的，我在看 DVD 笔记。这是该剧不一定遵循最严格规定的另一个例子。
If you go to 23 minutes and nine seconds when they're shooting paintballs at each other, there's a moment where rain as Dwight is running away from Steve and Steve shoots a paintball. And I think it hits him kind of like on his butt. And you hear rain go, ow. And so I heard it. Honest.
如果你转到 23 分 09 秒，当他们互相发射彩弹时，有一个时刻，雷恩饰演的德怀特从史蒂夫（Steve）身边跑开，史蒂夫开枪射出一颗彩弹。我想它大概击中了雷恩的屁股。然后你听到雷恩发出“哎哟”的声音。所以我听到了。真的。
I heard it. Yeah, I might be making this up. But I think they maybe undercrank the pressure just a little bit on the paintball guns so that it wasn't as painful. Make it a little safer. And they had all the padded suits on, too, which helped. But they're very close to one another.
我听到了。是的，我可能是瞎编的。但我认为他们可能把彩弹枪的压力调低了一点点，这样就不会那么疼了。稍微安全一点。而且他们还穿了所有加了垫子的衣服，这也很有帮助。但他们离得非常近。
I know. I sort of always imagined I've never played, but that paintball has more distance. You're supposed to be further away. This was also a callback to Dwight's secret Santa gift from season two. That's right. But he also shot paintball earlier in the show, right?
我知道。我某种程度上总是想象——我从来没玩过，但彩弹应该有更远的距离。你应该离得更远。这也是对第二季德怀特秘密圣诞礼物的呼应。没错。但他在这集前面也玩过彩弹，对吧？
He has. Yes. Many times. Yeah, it's been established. Well, Michael is going to smile. He can cross another name off his list. And Greg, I thought it was really interesting how Michael, the whole episode, has
他玩过。是的。很多次。是的，这已经设定好了。好吧，迈克要笑了。他又可以从他的名单上划掉一个名字了。格雷格，我觉得很有趣的是，迈克在整集中
to keep looking at the time. He's checking the time. We've established this. Got to make his plane. Yeah, this four o'clock time, and it made me anxious a little bit as I watched it, because I was so aware that we were coming to a close. And would that just you be brilliant?
不得不一直看时间。他在看时间。我们已经设定好了这一点。得赶上飞机。对啊，这个下午四点的时间，让我在看的时候有点焦虑，因为我很清楚我们要接近尾声了。这难道不是很绝妙吗？
No, that's intentional. But I mean, there's also a writing principle called the ticking clock, which often you need to add to a story because there's not enough tension, but it's not always cutting to a ticking clock. Sometimes it's disguised a little better. But the Michael Dwight relationship was such a big part of the show.
不，那是刻意的。但我的意思是，还有一个叫“滴答作响的时钟”的写作原则，通常你需要把它加入到一个故事中，因为张力不够，但它并不总是切到一个滴答作响的时钟。有时它伪装得更好一些。但迈克和德怀特的 RELATIONSHIP（关系）是该剧的重要组成部分。
So Dwight actually has, I think, a bunch of moments with Michael to say goodbye on this episode. And this was the big one that kind of extends to maybe a multi-arc thing of him wanting to take over the office and not getting it. But the paintball was more like their relationship was always, to me, Dwight was always like 15 years old, and Michael was nine years old, in terms
所以德怀特实际上在这集里和迈克有很多时刻来告别。这是最重磅的一个，它可能会延伸到关于他想接管办公室却没能得逞的多重故事线中。但彩弹更像是他们的关系一直给我的感觉：德怀特总是像 15 岁，而迈克像 9 岁，就
of what their personalities were like. And just if you think about how two boys at 15 and 9 would have dealt with an emotional goodbye, like a last paintball game would be the perfect thing. Yeah. You mentioned that tension of not knowing who's going to be the next boss and Dwight wanting to be the next boss.
他们的性格而言。如果你想想两个 15 岁和 9 岁的男孩会如何处理一场情绪化的告别，最后玩一场彩弹游戏会是最完美的事情。对啊。你提到了那种不知道谁会是下一个老板的紧张感，以及德怀特想成为下一个老板。
And I remember that happening in real life, in real time, to all of us on the set. There was no new person cast at this time. Like when we were shooting this episode, it wasn't like you had made an announcement, and you're like, OK, so here's the thing. We are going to bring in this person to be the next boss, or this character is going to be promoted.
我记得在现实生活中，在真实时间里，我们所有人在片场都经历过这种情况。当时并没有选定新演员。就像我们拍这一集的时候，并不是说你已经发布了公告，然后你说：好吧，事情是这样的。我们要把这个人带进来做下一任老板，或者这个角色要晋升。
So I felt like even in real life, there was this little bit of this sense of like, no, really, what happens when Steve leaves? Like, what happens? Yeah, well, I'm trying to remember back in that time frame. And again, Paul was running the show. So there's conversations I probably didn't hear. But there are a lot of people with opinions on it.
所以我感觉甚至在现实生活中，也有那么一点点这种感觉，就像：不，真的，当史蒂夫离开时会发生什么？就像，会发生什么？是的，好吧，我试着回想那个时间段。再说一次，保罗当时在掌管这部剧。所以有些对话我可能没听到。但有很多人对此有意见。
Because at the time, I think we were NBC's number one show. And that's a big move when you decide to keep going without the number one on the call sheet. That's a big decision. But I mean, there was a debate about it, and it wasn't 100% clear. Well, I feel like when we were reading scripts as a cast, we were like looking for clues, just like Dwight was.
因为当时，我认为我们是 NBC 收视率第一的节目。当你决定在没有收视榜首演员的情况下继续拍下去时，这是一个大动作。这是一个重大的决定。但我的意思是，对此有过争论，而且并不是 100% 明确的。好吧，我觉得当我们作为演员在读剧本时，我们就像德怀特一样在寻找线索。
Yeah, so Steve was a producer this year, obviously. And I remember discussing it with him because there was a moment where we were like, should we just end the show? And he didn't want to pull the plug on the party early. And every week, we cut really funny stuff from our ensemble. And if you look at our ensemble, they're all, at that time, just between Ed and Craig Robinson. There's an awful lot of people on that show
对啊，所以史蒂夫今年显然是制片人。我记得我和他讨论过这件事，因为当时我们有这样一个时刻，我们在想：我们是不是该直接把这部剧完结算了？他不想提前结束派对。而且每周，我们都会从我们的群像中剪掉很多非常搞笑的东西。如果你看看我们的群像，他们当时都在，就在爱德（Ed）和克雷格·罗宾逊（Craig Robinson）之间。这部剧里有相当多的人
who went on to have their own shows as stars of successful TV shows. So I think there was definitely I had this feeling of, it'll be very difficult without Steve. But we have this amazing ensemble, and they'll get more screen time. And they will develop new dynamics and new stories because of their excess, their extra screen time.
后来都去主演了自己的成功电视剧。所以我认为我绝对有这种感觉：没有史蒂夫会非常困难。但我们有这个了不起的群像阵容，他们会得到更多出场时间。而且由于他们的富余、额外的出场时间，他们会发展出新的动态和新的故事。
So I don't know if we had a real feeling like we had to know. Yeah, well, you did. I mean, this is a basketball term, obviously. But you had a deep bench, as they say. So I remember not being worried. Maybe I was just really naive about how things work. But when we found out that Will Ferrell was going to be there for a few episodes,
所以我不知道我们是否有一种必须要弄清楚的真实感觉。是的，好吧，你确实弄清楚了。我的意思是，这是一个篮球术语，显而易见。但就像他们说的，你们有很深的替补阵容。所以我记得我并不担心。也许我只是对事情的运作方式太天真了。但当我们发现威尔·法瑞尔要来演几集时，
I was like, oh, they're smart. They're really smart. We're going to have this great bridge. And they've got it all figured out. I think I'm just really trusting in like, oh, look at them. This is so smart. The sort of the cliffhanger at the end of the season was, who's it going to be?
我就想：哦，他们很聪明。他们真的很聪明。我们要有这座伟大的桥梁了。而且他们已经把一切都搞定了。我想我只是非常信任地觉得：哦，看他们。这太聪明了。季末的悬念是：到底会是谁？
And there was this job hunting. And I think partly that was because we maybe suddenly found that there was some pressure to name something. But we didn't have it because we were assuming we're just going to lean on the deep bench. But I will say that from a playwriting standpoint, it's harder to replace the central character, partly because of the dynamics of how the show was written.
而且有这样一场求职。我想部分原因是因为我们可能突然发现有一些指定人选的压力。但我们当时没有，因为我们假设我们会依靠深厚的替补阵容。但我得说，从剧作的角度来看，替换核心角色更难，部分原因在于这部剧的写作动态。
So for instance, Dwight was not conceived to be the central character. And I think he grew into it a lot more, especially through his relationship with Angela. And just as he matured, and I think by the time we ended the series, he was very three-dimensional, but didn't start that way. And I always also felt like Andy started
比如，德怀特最初并不是被构想为核心角色的。我认为他成长了很多，尤其是通过他与安吉拉的关系。随着他日趋成熟，我认为当我们结束这个系列时，他已经非常立体了，但一开始并非如此。而且我一直觉得安迪在第三季吉姆在斯坦福时
as the Connecticut Dwight in season three for Jim when he was in Stanford. So he had certain, like his anger management problems, like there were certain things that were built into Andy that also made it a little bit difficult. We weren't starting fresh with a person who was conceived to be the boss of the ensemble. But there's talent for days in our cast.
也是从康涅狄格州的德怀特开始的。所以他有某些特点，比如他的愤怒管理问题，安迪身上也有某些特质，这也让事情变得有点困难。我们并不是从一个被构想为群像老板的人开始全新的创作。但我们的演员阵容里有数不尽的天才。
You're so right, though. I hadn't thought of it from that point of view, but it's so clear when you say it that all these characters were exactly where they were supposed to be in sort of the placement of a story. Kate Flannery said this thing one time. We had gone to some red carpet thing, and we were being interviewed.
不过你说得太对了。我没有从那个角度想过，但当你这么说时，就很明显了，所有这些角色都在故事布局中处于他们应该在的位置。凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）有一次说了这样一句话。我们去参加某个红毯活动，然后我们在接受采访。
And we were walking the carpet together. It was early in the show. And the interviewer said the question was sort of like, what's it like to be a supporting character on the show? Is there a storyline that you've been excited about? Something like that. And Kate said, well, first of all, she said, I love being a supporting character on the show.
我们一起走红毯。那是节目的早期。采访者问的问题有点像是：作为剧中的配角是什么感觉？有没有哪个故事情节让你感到兴奋？诸如此类的话。凯特说，嗯，首先，她说，我喜欢做剧中的配角。
And she said, Meredith is not the entree. She's a little bit of seasoning. She's some spice. And I love being the seasoning and the spice, but I'm not the entree. And it always stuck with me because I was standing right next to her. And I was like, she had such a clear view of her character
她说，梅雷迪思（Meredith）不是主菜。她是一点调味品。她是一些香料。我喜欢做调味品和香料，但我不是主菜。这句话一直留在我心里，因为我当时就站在她旁边。我就想：她对自己的角色
and her role on the show. I just thought it was just so smart of Kate of how she answered that. Those questions can be tricky sometimes. They're thrown to you, and you're like, what do I say? And I never forgot it. And I carried it with me the whole entire rest of the show. I think Angela is the bitter greens on the plate.
以及她在剧中的角色有着如此清晰的看法。我只是觉得凯特回答得太聪明了。这些问题有时可能很棘手。它们抛向你，你就会想：我说什么好呢？我永远没有忘记它。我把它带进了节目的整个剩余部分。我觉得安吉拉是盘子里的苦绿色蔬菜。
I'm not sure what Pam is, maybe like a mushroom sauce or something. No. Yes. No, she's mashed potatoes. Potatoes, yeah. We think she's potatoes. Yes, I thought my first thing before you said potato
我不确定帕姆是什么，也许是蘑菇酱之类。不对。是的。不对，她是土豆泥。土豆，对。在我们说土豆之前，我的第一反应
was mashed potatoes. I thought that, you know, if Michael is the steak, then Pam is the mushroom sauce that makes the steak go down even smoother. Even better. But you're going to have steak without mushroom sauce. I guess I should. You can't have steak without potatoes.
就是土豆泥。我想，如果迈克是牛排，那么帕姆就是让牛排下咽更顺畅的蘑菇酱。更好。但你不能没有蘑菇酱吃牛排。我想我应该可以。你不能没有土豆吃牛排。
Okay, okay. I'll take it. Yeah. Well, we are on the sales call with D'Angelo and Andy. The client was played by Alfred Rubin Thompson. I don't know if you noticed, but at 23 minutes and 45 seconds, he has a CD on his desk that says currency converter. I loved this detail.
好吧，好吧。我接受。好吧，我们在和迪安杰洛以及安迪一起拜访客户。那个客户由阿尔弗雷德·鲁宾·汤普森（Alfred Rubin Thompson）饰演。我不知道你有没有注意到，在 23 分 45 秒时，他的桌子上有一张 CD，上面写着“货币转换器”。我喜欢这个细节。
Oh, that's a great detail. Way to go Steve Rothstein in our set dressing department. So this guy does something where he needs to convert currency. This is a great two-hander storyline for Ed and Will. And I think in this moment, Will is being very funny saying this horribly underminy speech about how Andy is as a flawed salesperson. But Ed is being equally funny reacting to it. And it's just, it's really a fun scene to see the two of them together.
哦，这是一个很棒的细节。真有你的，我们布景部的史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦（Steve Rothstein）。所以这家伙做的事情需要他进行货币转换。这是给爱德和威尔的一条很棒的双人故事线。我认为在这个时刻，威尔非常搞笑地说了一段可怕的贬低性台词，关于安迪作为一名有缺陷的销售员是怎么样的。但爱德的反应同样搞笑。这真的，看他们两个在一起是一场很有趣的戏。
They're very funny together. I needed Andy to have a win. Because I was watching this, I was like, please, please don't let the sale like get lost. And then when he goes back in and he is able to make the sale and then get the call, I was so happy. Yeah. Yeah. Well, it's interesting.
他们在一起非常搞笑。我需要安迪能赢一次。因为我在看的时候，我一直在想：求求你，求求你别让这笔生意丢了。然后当他走回去并成功做成这笔生意然后接到电话时，我太高兴了。对啊。是的。好吧，这很有趣。
One of the, when I refer back to the episodes in the beginning of season two where we kind of rebuilt Michael, one of the big ones was the client that Paul wrote. Where he reveals that he may not be a great manager, but he was really good as a sales person. And I think maybe we were doing a little bit here with Ed to try to build him up for the long term for season eight. Yeah. So apparently part of Pam's process for pricing shredders is going to the movies and she's
其中一个，当我回想起第二季初期的那些我们重塑了迈克的集数时，其中一大集就是保罗写的那个客户。在那里他透露他可能不是个好经理，但他在做销售方面真的很棒。我想也许我们这里也在对爱德做一点尝试，为第八季的长远发展来塑造他。对啊。所以显然帕姆给碎纸机定价的过程的一部分是去看电影，她
going to sneak off and see the King's Speech. It's a really great movie, you guys. It is a good movie. I enjoyed it when I saw it. I really did too. I find also to me, the fact that Pam would pick a Colin Firth movie to sneak off to is very telling. It's very Pam.
要溜去看《国王的演讲》（The King's Speech）。这是一部真的很棒的电影，伙计们。这确实是一部好电影。我当年看的时候很喜欢。我真的很喜欢。而且对我来说，帕姆会挑一部科林·费斯（Colin Firth）的电影溜去看，这说明了很多问题。这非常帕姆。
We shot that in Pomona. It was the morning that we did the airport scene. So while they were sort of setting up the airport and building out that set, we sneaked away and we shot on the street. You can see they did their best to frame out the word Pomona on the big sign above the movie theater. But you can, if you know that's what it says, that you can still kind of see it. But I thought that the coolest thing they did was if you look for it, you can see it's
我们在波莫纳（Pomona）拍摄的。那是我们拍机场戏的那个早晨。所以当他们正在布置机场并搭建那个布景时，我们溜了出去，在街上拍了戏。你可以看到他们尽最大努力把电影院上方大招牌上的“波莫纳”这个词用构图挡住了。但如果你知道那就是它上面写的，你还是能看出来。但我认为他们做过的最酷的事情是，如果你仔细找找，你会发现那不是一个遮阳篷。
not a marquee. You know, in the glass box next to the movie theater, we put a poster for Bridesmaids. Yeah. Oh, yes. Ellie and Paul. Yes. I'm curious. Do you guys think that Jim knew that Pam was going to see a movie?
你知道的，在电影院旁边的玻璃框里，我们贴了一张《伴娘》（Bridesmaids）的海报。对啊。哦，是的。艾莉（Ellie）和保罗。是的。我很想知道。你们觉得吉姆知道帕姆要去看电影吗？
I don't think he did. I don't either. I don't either. No, this is her thing. This is her time. Because it's Colin Firth. I used to do this at a job that I had as a media buyer. You would sneak off and watch movies?
我觉得他不知道。我也不知道。我也不知道。不，这是她的事。这是她的时间。因为那是科林·费斯。我以前在我做媒体买家的那份工作里也这么干过。你会溜出去看电影？
Well, part of our job, because we bought time to advertise movies, part of our job was that we got to leave to go see screenings of movies. That was really cool. But we would, after the movie, my girlfriend and I, who both worked there around the corner from the screening area, was a place where you could get a manicure pedicure and we would just tack one on to the end of our day out. It was kind of fun. That's the best is when you have a job where there's an excuse for you to be out of the
好吧，我们工作的一部分，因为我们买时间来做电影广告，我们工作的一部分就是我们可以离开去看电影的试映。那真的很酷。但我们会在看完电影后，我和我的女伴，我们俩都在离试映区拐角处的那家公司工作，那里有一个可以做美甲和足疗的地方，我们就会在我们的外出日结束时顺便加上这个。这挺有趣的。最好的情况就是你有这样一份工作，你有借口离开
office. Right. That's slightly fuzzy about when you're going to get back. Yeah. Exactly. I did do this when I interned on Conan. If they would send us on a run, you would just go sit for a little bit in a coffee shop. Take your time.
办公室。对啊。而且关于你什么时候能回去，时间有点模糊。对啊。没错。我在柯南（Conan）那里实习时确实这么干过。如果他们派我们出去跑腿，你就会去咖啡馆里坐一会儿。慢慢来。
Have a snack. Enjoy a tea in Central Park. I was a proofreader in one job and it was in the very small publishing house. It was in a guy's house and he had a three-story house and there were two, I had two bosses. One of them was on the first floor and one of them was on the third floor. Sometimes I would just go to the second floor and just hang out with the other. They were like, oh, he must be down on the first floor working on that guy project. Well, Michael is going to have his very last conference room meeting, Greg.
吃个零食。在中央公园享受一杯茶。我曾在一份工作中做过校对，那是在一家非常小的出版社。它在一个人的家里，那是一栋三层的房子，有两个，我有两个老板。其中一个在一楼，另一个在三楼。有时我就会直接去二楼，和另一个老板闲逛。他们就会想：哦，他一定在一楼和那家伙一起做那个项目呢。好吧，迈克要有他的最后一次会议室会议了，格雷格。
Did you think a lot about how you wanted him to have a conference room meeting in this episode? Well, I think he's getting panicked because his time is running out and I think that he enjoyed conference room meetings because he was able to use them as tryouts for a stand-up and have a captive audience. Yeah. He calls one without really knowing what he's going to say, I think. Which is very on brand because I feel like Michael called a lot of meetings like that.
你有没有想过很多关于你希望他在这一集里开一次会议室会议的细节？好吧，我想他开始恐慌了，因为他的时间快用完了，而且我认为他喜欢会议室会议，因为他能够利用它们作为单口相声的试演，并拥有一个无法离开的听众。对啊。他在不知道自己要说什么的情况下就召集了一次，我想。这非常符合他的性格，因为我觉得迈克经常召集那样的会议。
I was very sad that I was not in the last conference room meeting. This was a bummer for me. These are some of my happiest times on set. Yeah. That was rough. Well, if you go to 28 minutes and three seconds, I know this is what everyone's looking for in this scene. My hair is back in the clip again.
我非常难过我没有参加最后一次会议室会议。这对我是个打击。这些是我在片场最快乐的时光。对啊。那太糟糕了。好吧，如果你转到 28 分 03 秒，我知道这是每个人在这场戏里都在寻找的。我的头发又别回发夹里了。
Oh, good. The continuity has returned. That's what struck me the first time when we saw this. I was like... What's up with Angela's hair clip? Angela's hair is back. Yeah. All will be right with the world.
哦，太好了。连戏又回来了。这是我们第一次看到这个时首先击中我的点。我就想……安吉拉的发夹怎么回事？安吉拉的头发又盘起来了。对啊。世界一切正常了。
Well, in this conference room meeting, Jim is going to figure out that something is going on and he asks Michael if he can speak to him in his office. I mean, Michael's getting a little unhinged and Jim is the most perceptive, so he is the one who's going to figure this out. When did you decide that Jim was going to be the person who figures it out? Well, everybody has their moment with Michael and Jim, it just seems like Michael is sort of graduating psychologically into being a wiser character here as he's going to float above the office into the clouds.
好吧，在这场会议室会议中，吉姆将发现有什么不对劲，他问迈克是否能在他的办公室和他谈谈。我的意思是，迈克有点精神崩溃了，而吉姆是最敏锐的，所以他是那个会发现这一点的人。你是什么时候决定让吉姆成为发现这一点的人的？好吧，每个人和迈克都有他们的时刻，而吉姆，这只是感觉迈克在这里正心理上晋升为一个更明智的角色，因为他将飘浮在办公室上方进入云端。
There is this little ruse going in the middle of the show. For Jim to have a moment and not be in on it, it seemed like it was good for his character that he figures it out and then they can have the only sincere conversation. Right. We started to roll on the last day and it was the only sincere conversation and it got very emotional. Yeah. This was the second to last scene that we shot that day was the scene between Michael
剧中中间有这样一个小把戏。为了让吉姆有一刻蒙在鼓里，对他的角色来说，让他发现真相，然后他们能进行唯一一次真诚的对话，这似乎很合适。没错。我们在最后一天开始开机，这是唯一一次真诚的对话，而且变得非常感人。是的。这是我们那天拍摄的倒数第二场戏，是迈克尔
and Jim in Michael's office. Well, if you guys have the DVD box set, it's definitely worth watching this scene because it's a bigger scene. There is this great beat in the middle of it, Greg, which I understand why it was probably deleted just because the flow of the scene is so perfect, but it's such a great detail. So Michael is going to share with Jim that he has a job interview already set up in Colorado. It's for a paper company that makes the ticket stubs for all the movie theaters. And he says, you know, it's perfect to combines both my loves movies and paper.
和吉姆在迈克尔办公室里的戏。嗯，如果你有DVD套装，绝对值得一看这场戏，因为它是一场更大的戏。格雷格，中间有一个很棒的节拍，我理解为什么它可能被删掉，只是因为这场戏的节奏太完美了，但这真是一个极好的细节。所以迈克尔要跟吉姆分享他已经在科罗拉多安排好了一场工作面试。是一家为所有电影院制作电影票根的造纸公司。他说，你知道，这太完美了，结合了我的两大爱好——电影和纸。
And I just thought that was such a great detail. I like to know in my brain like, you know, where Michael is, where he's living, what he's up to. I just sort of see him working for the ticket stub paper company. Yeah. Well, you know, my dad had two great friends growing up Dick Town and Tom Hazen. And I can't remember which one. One of them had a family paper company and they transitioned into tickets and that saved
我只是觉得这真是一个绝妙的细节。我脑海里喜欢知道，你知道的，迈克尔在哪里，他住在哪里，他在忙些什么。我只是有点看到他在为那个票根造纸公司工作。是的。嗯，你知道，我爸成长过程中有两个好朋友，迪克·汤姆和汤姆·黑森。我记不清是哪一个了。其中一个有一家家族造纸公司，他们转型做票根，这拯救了
a lot of small or at least it really helped small paper company because it was a very high tech form of paper. It had all these embossed, you know, things in it and everything. I was probably on somebody's phone now, so it's probably was only a temporary reprieve. But I remember being told that around that time. And it did seem like a great job for Michael because it was paper, but it was a little show busy paper, you know, but the thing about that scene is when it got so sort of real and John was saying stuff to the actor Steve Carell about how he felt about working with
许多小型造纸公司，或者至少它确实极大地帮助了小型造纸公司，因为这是一种非常高科技的纸张形式。它上面有所有这些压花工艺，你知道的，还有各种东西。现在可能在某人的手机上，所以这可能只是暂时的喘息之机。但我记得当时有人跟我这么说过。这似乎确实是迈克尔的一份好工作，因为它是纸，但它是有点演艺圈性质的纸，你知道的，但那场戏的关键在于，当它变得如此真实，约翰对演员史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说起他对与
him for seven years, it started to really spread. And you could you were like, God, this, this can't be an eight minute scene. So we were throwing lines out, you know, in the editing room, it was just, it was just down to the sort of the nub version of it. But it was, it came out well, I think, and it was emotional to watch them. It was emotional to rewatch when, you know, Jim says, but we clearly just saw John in the moment saying when he said, you're the best boss I've ever had. I was just like, forget it, I'm a mess.
他合作七年的感受时，这种情绪真的开始蔓延开来。你会觉得，天哪，这，这不能是一场八分钟的戏。所以在剪辑室里，我们在删掉一些台词，你知道的，它被精简到了那种核心版本。但它效果很好，我认为，看着他们让人百感交集。重看时也让人百感交集，当，你知道，吉姆说，但我们分明看到约翰在那个当下说出“你是我遇到过最好的老板”时，我当时就想，算了，我整个人都不好了。
Right. George Clooney and Leatherheads didn't compare. We had a fan catch from Juliana R. and Atlanta, Georgia, who said, I have a fan catch. Michael forgot his voice recorder in his desk on the last day, you know, in that scene, he gets out his voice recorder because he has a t-shirt idea goodbye, and he puts it back in the drawer. And he left without it. Yes, Justin A. from Buffalo, New York noticed this as well and wanted to know, was this
没错。乔治·克鲁尼和《爱情达阵》根本没法比。我们收到了来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的朱莉安娜·R的粉丝趣闻，她说，我有一个粉丝趣闻。迈克尔在最后一天把他的录音机忘在桌上了，你知道的，在那场戏里，他拿出了他的录音机，因为他有一个告别T恤的想法，然后他把它放回了抽屉里。结果他走的时候没拿。是的，纽约州布法罗市的贾斯蒂娜·A也注意到了这一点，并且想知道，这
an intentional joke because they both really enjoyed it. They both enjoyed the fact that he forgot to bring it. Yes, yes, but he left, he walks out without his voice recorder with all his good ideas on it. Yeah. Oh, goodness. I don't think that was intentional, but I'm glad that they're perceiving it as a joke. Own it.
是有意安排的笑话吗，因为他们俩真的很喜欢这个设定。他们俩都很享受他忘带录音机这个事实。对，对，但他走了，他走的时候没有带那个存着他所有好点子的录音机。对。哦，天哪。我不认为那是故意的，但我很高兴他们把这看作是一个笑话。欣然接受吧。
Yeah. I like the idea that it's a wonderful leave behind for the next boss. Right. A drawer full of amazing ideas. Like that t-shirt. Yeah. I love that. I mean, that was a running thing for Michael as a character is that he would sometimes
对。我喜欢这个想法，觉得这是留给下一任老板的一份美妙的遗产。没错。一抽屉惊人的点子。就像那件T恤。Yeah。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，对迈克尔这个角色来说，这是一个贯穿始终的设定，那就是他有时会
interrupt himself to have a great idea that we're always terrible. Do you do that as a writer? Are you ever somewhere or at dinner? Do you have a place where you put observations or ideas? Do you have a writer's notebook? I have scraps because I don't ever have the special writer's notebook with me. Of course. So, but I do have a box in my house and I'll tear, you know, I'll throw in the napkin or
打断自己去想一个伟大的主意，而这些主意通常都糟糕透顶。你作为编剧会这样吗？你有没有在某个地方或者吃晚饭时，有一个专门记录观察或想法的地方？你有一个编剧笔记本吗？我只有废纸片，因为我从来不会随身携带那种特别的编剧笔记本。当然。所以，但我家里确实有一个盒子，我会撕下，你知道的，我会把餐巾纸或者
the back of the envelope and I'll throw it into the box. And then so, then you sit down, you have to write a new script or come up with a new character. Do you open the box and it's like, you look for the magical scrap that's going to be the seed. The much pod over scraps. They're down to like really useless scraps at this point. I've used everything I possibly can. Well, why don't we take a break because when we come back, it's Michael's last bullpen
信封背面扔进盒子里。然后，当你坐下来必须写一剧本或者构思一个新角色时，你会打开那个盒子，就像在寻找将成为种子的神奇纸片吗？那些被反复琢磨的纸片。到了这个时候，它们已经沦为真正没用的废纸片了。我能用得上的全用过了。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下，因为当我们回来时，这将是迈克尔在办公区的最后一场戏了
scene ever. We'll be back. Well, we are back and here it is. This is Michael's last bullpen scene. This is the last thing we filmed with Steve Carell on the office. He just walks out into the bullpen. He takes his unfinished mittens from Phyllis and he just stands there and looks at this ordinary workday.
有史以来最后一场。我们马上回来。好吧，我们回来了，重头戏来了。这是迈克尔的最后一场办公区戏。这是我们在《办公室》中与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔拍摄的最后一场戏。他只是走进了办公区。他拿走了菲利斯给他织了一半的手套，然后就站在那里，看着这个平凡的工作日。
I remember going to the mix for this and cranking the sounds, the ordinary sounds of the office. The phones ringing and the things. Yeah. And the backs machines and stuff. Yeah. And we had tons of those. We had tracks for every type of like dot matrix printer, you know, over the years and we just sort of like threw it all in like, you know, jack it up.
我记得我去参加这场戏的混音时，把声音调得很大，也就是办公室里那些平常的声音。电话铃声和各种杂音。是的。还有传真机之类的。是的。我们有海量的这种音效。多年来，我们有针对各种点阵打印机的音轨，你知道的，我们只是把它们全部扔进去，就像，你知道的，把音量拉满。
And there was this, I thought it was something where it was like an opportunity to just remind people of the sound of what it was. So to me, the sound was as important as the picture on that thing. You know, in the finale, you gave Pam that line about the beauty of ordinary things. But I feel like that is the story of this episode as well. Yeah. It's in here for sure. Yeah.
而且我觉得这是一个机会，可以借此提醒人们那是怎样的一种声音。所以对我来说，那个声音和那场戏里的画面一样重要。你知道，在大结局中，你让帕姆说出了那句关于平凡事物的美好的台词。但我觉得这也是这一集的主题。是的。这里面绝对有。是的。
That theme. Yeah. So it's inherent in a documentary that you're looking at real people. Yeah. But then it goes back to that poor guy who retired from SoCal gas. Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
那个主题。是的。所以，纪录片里展现真实人物是理所当然的。是的。但随后它又回溯到了那个从南加州天然气公司退休的可怜家伙身上。是的。完全正确。是的。
Do you remember because I, so I was not in the scene, but I was there because after we shot this day, we had a big goodbye party for Steve. So I had come up to the set and I wanted to see his last scene in the bullpen. So I was at video village and I was watching this. And I remember that we did do a version where Michael turns out all the lights on everybody as he's leaving. Yeah. Do you remember that?
你还记得吗，因为我，我当时不在那场戏里，但我当时在现场，因为在我们拍摄完这一天后，我们为史蒂夫举办了一个盛大的告别派对。所以我来到了片场，我想看他在办公区的最后一场戏。所以我当时在视频监视区看着这一切。我记得我们确实拍了一个版本，是迈克尔在离开时把所有人的灯都关了。是的。你还记得吗？
Yeah. We like yell at him like, Michael. Yes. Yeah. That was going to be a big joke. Right. That he assumed that when he left, the whole thing was, did nobody need it to have light? Exactly.
记得。我们冲他大喊，迈克尔。是的。是的。那本来是个大笑话。没错。他以为他一走，整栋楼就，难道没有人需要光吗？完全正确。
Yeah. I think that was hard too because there are windows. I don't think it was as like, I know we shot it. Yeah. And I remember it, I think we had some problems with it from an emotional standpoint is like, it was kind of negative when it was otherwise a very positive sort of beat. But I also think it didn't execute enormously well because of the windows. So it's like, it didn't get really that dark.
是的。我觉得那也很难拍，因为有窗户。我觉得它不像，我知道我们拍了。是的。而且我记得，从情感角度来看，我觉得它有些问题，因为当它本该是一个非常积极的节拍时，那种行为有点消极。但我也觉得由于窗户的存在，它的执行效果并不是非常好。所以，它并没有真的变得那么黑。
So, you know. Yeah. Yeah. So there's a great moment at the end when Michael's watching everyone work and Jim clocks Michael. And Greg, you shared on the commentary that it wasn't scripted, but that the camera guys just caught the moment and that you loved it and it was so perfect. Is that where Jim kind of gives him a little like, you can go? Yeah.
所以，你知道的。是的。是的。所以在最后有一个很棒的时刻，迈克尔看着每个人工作，吉姆注意到了迈克尔。格雷格，你在随片评论中分享过，这不是剧本里写好的，而是摄影师恰好捕捉到了那一刻，而且你非常喜欢它，它简直完美。那就是吉姆有点给他那种“你可以走了”的眼神吗？是的。
You got this. Yeah. Like a little head, like get out of here. Yeah. Kind of head nod. And Michael smiles and nods and then he walks out. Yeah. And we know he's going to heaven paradise with Holly.
你行的。是的。就像一个小动作，像“离开这儿”。是的，那种点头。迈克尔微笑并点头，然后他走了出去。是的。我们知道他要和霍莉去天堂了。
But there's also a little bit of like, Michael's at the death bed of his dad. I guess that's where Brent's getting this from because he's like, I release you. Yeah. You know what I mean? Yeah. Yeah. And he maybe needed that last little look from Jim, that last little nudge of like assurance. It's going to be okay.
但其中也有一点像是，迈克尔正守在他爸爸的临终病床前。我猜布伦特就是从这里得到灵感的，因为他就像是在说“我放过你了”。是的。你知道我的意思吗？是的。是的。他可能需要来自吉姆的最后一眼，那最后一点带有保证意味的推力。一切都会好起来的。
Yeah. Yeah. Well, I remember Nancy Carell had come up and was watching this last scene as well. Yeah. On the monitors. And that was really special. And from a personal standpoint, I remember standing in the conference room. Michael's realtor?
是的。是的。嗯，我记得南茜·卡瑞尔也过来看了这场最后的戏。是的。就在监视器前。那真的特别。从我个人的角度来说，我记得我站在会议室里。迈克尔的房地产经纪人？
Why would she? Carol? Why did Carol come back? Carol wanted to be there. But I remember being in the conference room and I was pregnant when we shot this episode and I had not told anyone except for Angela. And I remember just wrestling with whether or not I should tell Nancy or if I should get Steve aside because I did not know when I would see them again.
她为什么会来？卡罗尔？卡罗尔为什么回来？卡罗尔想去。但我记得在会议室里，我们拍这集的时候我怀孕了，除了安吉拉，我没有告诉任何人。我记得我当时在纠结，我是该告诉南茜，还是把史蒂夫拉到一边，因为我不知道什么时候还能再见到他们。
And all Steve ever wanted was for me to have the family that I always wanted, you know? I just knew how excited he would be for me. I did not tell them. I stayed quiet. I remember urging you to have a baby. Greg, you were urging me to have a baby from like the pilot. Like all you did was go around and encourage cast members to start families. Because you are such a family guy and you love family and you, I do remember this though.
而史蒂夫唯一想要的，就是让我拥有我一直渴望的家庭，你知道吗？我只是知道他会为我多么兴奋。我没有告诉他们。我保持了沉默。我记得当时你在催我生孩子。格雷格，你从试播集开始就一直在催我生孩子。你做的事就是到处鼓励演员们组建家庭。因为你是个十足的顾家男人，你热爱家庭，而且你，我确实记得这件事。
You were like, when are you guys going to start having babies? Well, I also felt really, because it was countered the interests as a producer and I always felt like I just want to make sure I'm completely on record of supporting anybody having a baby. The last thing I want for somebody to come back and go, I missed having a baby. Right, right. I felt pressure not to have a baby or something, but yeah. Yeah. But I just remember holding on to that little secret while I was standing there watching
你当时说，你们什么时候开始生孩子？嗯，我也觉得，因为这与作为一个制片人的利益相悖，我总是觉得我想确保自己完全公开地支持任何人去生孩子。我最不希望的就是有人回来对我说，我错过了生孩子的机会。对，对。我觉得有一种压力不能生孩子什么的，但对。是的。但我只记得当时站在那里看着
this last scene and wondering when am I ever going to see Steve again? Well, you probably did the right thing. This is a big moment in their lives. So it's probably, you know, maybe I shouldn't have made it past me. Goodbye, Steve. And guess what? I'm pregnant. You guys come to my, I'm having a baby party right after we wrap.
这场最后的戏时，心里死死守着那个小秘密，同时在想，我到底什么时候才能再见到史蒂夫？嗯，你可能做对了。这是他们生活中的重大时刻。所以可能，你知道，也许我不应该在这个时候说出来。再见，史蒂夫。你猜怎么着？我怀孕了。你们来我的，我正在举办一个开机杀青后的生孩子派对。
Yeah. It's down in the warehouse. In the corner, there's a going away party for Steve, but the real party. Michael is going to have a talking head that he got to say goodbye to almost everyone and that Holly is his family now. But right before this talking head, there would have been a deleted scene between Michael and Hank and Michael's waiting for his taxi, but he decides to buy one last cup of coffee from Hank and tries to give Hank a big tip.
对。就在仓库的角落里，那里正在为史蒂夫举办欢送派对，但真正的派对。迈克尔会有一个单人访谈，他在访谈中得以向几乎所有人告别，并说霍莉现在是他的家人了。但在这次单人访谈之前，本来会有一场迈克尔和汉克的被删减戏份，迈克尔在等他的出租车，但他决定向汉克买最后一杯咖啡，并试图给汉克一大笔小费。
And then Hank, you know, gives him a lot of sass and then it just all backfires. It was just like perfect Hank Michael scenario. Hugh was a great actor and they had a relationship and that should have been in the show, but it was awkwardly placed because we were racing towards the ending now. Yes. We didn't really have time to slow it down again and have this interaction. Yes. It was a great deleted scene.
然后汉克，你知道的，对他态度很不客气，结果这一切都适得其反。这就像是完美的汉克与迈克尔式的场景。休是个伟大的演员，他们之间有一种关系，这本该出现在剧中的，但它被放在了一个尴尬的位置，因为我们当时正赶着迎向结局。是的。我们真的没有时间再次慢下来并进行这种互动。是的。这是一个极好的被删减场景。
It's nice to see. Because it works so well that the taxi pulls up when Michael's with Jim, you know, and it's so abrupt he's leaving and so to then have this extra beat where then he's waiting for his taxi. Yeah. I think it was also sort of conceived of as his really is lingering because he wants to see Pam, but it was that was sort of implied elsewhere. Well, he is going to get to see Pam.
看到它真好。因为出租车在迈克尔和吉姆在一起时开过来，这个效果太棒了，你知道的，他离开得如此突然，所以如果再有一个额外的桥段让他等待出租车。是的。我想这也算是一种构思，表现他恋恋不舍，因为他想见帕姆，但这在别处已经暗示过了。好吧，他确实能见到帕姆。
We don't know it yet. Yes. But we follow Michael to the airport. He's going through a security check, but he also made a choice to go to the airport even if he had to miss Pam. Yes. He doesn't know he's going to see Pam, which is important. I think so too.
我们现在还不知道。是的。但我们跟随迈克尔去了机场。他正在通过安检，但他同时也做出了要去机场的选择，哪怕他可能会错过帕姆。是的。他不知道自己会见到帕姆，这很重要。我也这么觉得。
I think it's kind of like, because he started off, everybody at this office is my family and then he gets to have this talking head where he kind of recalibrates it. It's still super important, but he knows who his family is going to be. Now, you guys know that there's nothing I love more than a location report, but I'm going to let Amanda S. from Rancho Santa Margarita, California take this one. Amanda said, I know a bit about this location breakdown. The airport scene was filmed at the Ontario International Airport in Ontario, California. I grew up in the neighboring city of Rancho Cucamonga and recognized it right away.
我觉得有点像是，因为他一开始说“这个办公室里的所有人都是我的家”，然后他有了一次单人访谈，在访谈中他重新调整了这种认知。这依然超级重要，但他清楚谁才是他真正的家人。现在，你们知道没有什么比外景地报道更让我开心的了，但我打算让加利福尼亚州兰乔圣玛格丽塔的阿曼达·S来讲述这个。阿曼达说，我对这个外景地的幕后了解一点。机场的戏是在加利福尼亚州安大略的安大略国际机场拍摄的。我在邻近的兰乔库卡蒙格市长大，一眼就认出来了。
I don't know if they chose this airport because LAX wouldn't let you go back, but I do know that Ontario had lost a lot of traffic around this time due to the 2008 recession and ownership issues, so maybe it was just an easier option because it was so quiet. Well, I reached out to Randy Cordray. He said, Amanda is right. Where'd it go, Amanda? Yes. We shot this at the Ontario Airport in a closed terminal that was not open to the public.
我不知道他们选择这个机场是不是因为洛杉矶国际机场（LAX）不让人进去，但我知道安大略机场在那个时候由于2008年经济衰退和所有权问题失去了很多客流量，所以也许它只是一个更容易的选择，因为它非常安静。嗯，我联系了兰迪·科德雷。他说，阿曼达是对的。它去哪了，阿曼达？是的。我们在安大略机场的一个不对公众开放的封闭航站楼里拍摄的。
Everyone you see is a hired extra. The TSA check-in was set dressing brought in by us, but in order to shoot there, there were a lot of rules. Any cast or crew member who was shooting there that day got this memo, this very detailed memo, outlining the strict rules for being there, I have my memo. It says, hi all. I love a memo with rules. You know I love a memo.
你看到的每个人都是雇来的群演。安检处是我们运来的布景，但要在那里拍摄，有很多规矩。当天在那里拍摄的任何演员或剧组人员都收到了这份备忘录，这份非常详细的备忘录列出了在那里的严格规定，我带着我的备忘录呢。上面写着，大家好。我喜欢带规矩的备忘录。你知道我喜欢备忘录。
I love a memo. Hi all. As we get ready to shoot at the Ontario Airport, there are a few things you need to know. It says, you will be working in a closed terminal, but within the control of the TSA, so just because it was closed, don't think there's no rules, okay? You had to have your government issued ID in order to enter. You had to wear an office ID badge at all times. All crew members entering the airport were screened by TSA agents with dogs.
我太喜欢备忘录了。大家好。当我们准备在安大略机场拍摄时，有几件事你需要知道。上面写着，你将在一个封闭的航站楼工作，但在TSA（运输安全管理局）的控制范围内，所以千万别觉得因为它是封闭的就没规矩了，好吗？你必须出示政府签发的身份证件才能进入。你必须随时佩戴办公室工牌。所有进入机场的剧组人员都要接受带有警犬的TSA人员的安检。
What? Yeah. Wanted you to know that all explosives, firearms, and narcotics are prohibited. That was bolded, all caps, and underlined. If you have handled pyrotechnics or firearms in the last 30 days, you need to let them know because that residue can live on your clothing for 30 days. And if a dog alerts that you have any of these residues on you, you will be made to leave. Is that all?
什么？是的。想要让你们知道，所有爆炸物、火器和麻醉品都是违禁品。这句话是用粗体、全大写并加了下划线的。如果你在过去30天内接触过烟火或枪支，你需要让他们知道，因为这种残留物可以在你的衣服上存活30天。如果警犬报警提示你身上有这些残留物，你将被勒令离开。就这些吗？
There's more. That would happen to you? Oh, it doesn't sound like you'll be arrested, but you're not going to get to be in the shoot day. In the deserted terminal of the Ontario Airport, yeah. Once you're in the airport, bold all caps and underlined do not open any doors. If you open a door, you could be fined $11,000. What if you have to pee?
还有呢。那会发生在你身上吗？哦，听起来你不会被捕，但你没法参加当天的拍摄了。在安大略机场荒凉的航站楼里，是的。一旦你进入机场，粗体全大写加下划线：严禁打开任何门。如果你开了一门，你可能会被罚款11,000美元。如果你想嘘嘘怎么办？
Don't open the door. I don't know. You cannot open a door. I don't think stall doors are part of that. I meant like exterior doors. Like a door to a bathroom. No, that would go into a bathroom. Do you pee out in the world?
别开门。我不知道。你不能开门。我觉得隔间门不属于这个范畴。我的意思是像外门。比如去洗手间的门。不，那是通往洗手间的。难道你在户外随便嘘嘘吗？
Don't you go into an interior bathroom? I'm saying the door to go into the bathroom. That's not included. They mean any doors, you can't just open a door and like walk around outside and have a cigarette. Go down on the tarmac. Once you're inside, do not open a door. Now your line makes sense to me, do you just pee out in the world?
难道你不会去里面的洗手间吗？我说的是进洗手间的门。那不包括在内。他们的意思是任何门，你不能随便开一扇门然后走到外面去抽根烟。走到停机坪上去。一旦你在里面，就不要开门。现在你的台词我听懂了，你难道就在户外随便嘘嘘吗？
I was like, what is Greg saying? Doesn't everyone pee out in the world somewhere? Supposedly it does at your home. Bold and italics, this memo would like you to know that the $11,000 fine is a personal fine to you and BC will not be paying it. So if you open that door, it's on you. And the final note is that because of the nature of work for the Grip Electric and Props Department, knives will be allowed because they did have to use a knife.
我当时想，格雷格在说什么呀。难道不是每个人都在户外的某个地方嘘嘘吗？据说你是在家里。加粗并斜体，这份备忘录想让你知道，11,000美元的罚款是对你个人的罚款，NBC是不会替你付的。所以如果你开了那扇门，后果自负。最后一条注意事项是，由于灯光、电力和道具部门的工作性质，允许携带刀具，因为他们确实需要使用刀具。
However, it must be kept in your pocket when not in use. Do not set down your knife. Do not turn away. It must go into your pocket. If it does not go back in your pocket, that's another $11,000. Wow. Thank you for your cooperation. Please call if you have any questions.
但是，不用时必须放在口袋里。不要放下你的刀。不要转身。必须放进口袋里。如果没有放回口袋里，又是11,000美元罚款。哇。谢谢您的合作。如有任何问题，请致电。
Who was that signed by? Steve Burgess. Typical. I wonder how the airport settled on $11,000. It's such a specific number. It's probably like $10,000 to one thing and then someone gets a $1,000 cut. Why is that where my brain goes? I don't know.
那是谁署名的？史蒂夫·伯吉斯。真典型。我很好奇机场是怎么定出11,000美元这个数字的。这是一个如此具体的数字。可能是一万块钱算作一项，然后某人拿一千块的回扣。为什么我的大脑会往这方面想？我不知道。
Someone's on the side hustle. That's an agency fee. Yeah, someone's like, add $1,000 for the reps. Well, Michael has now gone through security and he's going to say, hey, will you guys let me know if this thing ever airs and then he takes off his mic pack and he says, feels good to get this off my chest and that's where you see him mouth the words. That's what she said. Yes.
有人在搞副业。那是中介费。是的，有人会说，给代表加一千块吧。嗯，迈克尔现在已经通过了安检，他要说，嘿，如果这东西播出了，你们能告诉我一声吗？然后他摘下麦克风包，说道：“把这个卸下来感觉真好”，然后就在那里，你看到他无声地说出了那句话。那就是她说的。是的。
Greg, you got one in the episode. Yeah, but it was a silent. Yeah. Yeah. I loved it though. You couldn't have Michael's last episode without that. Yeah. But it's almost like in a concert where the performer goes to their chorus and then just
格雷格，你在这一集里中了一个。是的，但那是无声的。是的。是的。不过我很喜欢。没有那个，你就没法拍迈克尔的最后一集。是的。但这几乎就像在一场演唱会上，表演者唱到副歌时
points the mic at the crowd and they all. They all sing it. They all sing, you know, the chorus. It's like everybody knew what he was going to say, so he didn't have to say it. People just shouted at the TV. Jenna, how was the scene for you? You go running up as Pam. I loved that I could see your pantyhose.
把麦克风指向观众，然后他们全场。他们全场大合唱。他们全场齐唱，你知道的，副歌部分。就像每个人都知道他要说什么一样，所以他不用说出口。人们只是对着电视大喊。珍娜，这场戏对你来说怎么样？你作为帕姆跑了过来。我很高兴我能看到你的连裤袜。
Your commitment to wearing pantyhose all these years on the show. We finally paid off. I refused to wear them. I never wore them. And you have your shoes in your hand. It's such a sweet moment. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
你这么多年在节目中坚持穿连裤袜的执着。我们终于得到了回报。我拒绝穿。我从来没穿过。而且你手里还拿着鞋子。这真是个温馨的时刻。嗯——嗯。是的。
And people always mention how did Pam get through TSA without a ticket? You know, how did she get through? And I remember having that discussion on set and we did actually shoot me. I remember there was this shot of me like running up and like pointing and like convincing them and then somehow they're like letting me through and they were like, that would never happen. So then we just had me sort of arrive there with my shoes in my hand and everything. There's a bunch of things that are a little like fudged there, I would say.
人们总是提到帕姆是怎么没票就通过安检的？你知道的，她是怎么通过的？我记得我们在片场讨论过这个问题，而且我们确实拍了我跑过来并指着前方试图说服他们，然后他们不知怎么让我通过的镜头，当时大家都觉得，这绝对不可能发生。所以后来我们就拍成了我手里拿着鞋子直接出现在那里的效果。我要说的是，那里有一堆事情处理得有点儿像糊弄过关。
I think Paul did a great job shooting it. I think it looks very real, you know, and he had all this big time movie experience and he really used the extras well and it looks like a complete functioning airport. Totally. When you think about it, the security, I mean, he walked right through security into a gate practically. Yeah. I mean, I don't see a lot of security that are that close, but I mean, maybe, you know,
我觉得保罗（费格）把它拍得很棒。我觉得它看起来非常真实，你知道的，他有着丰富的电影拍摄经验，他把群演用得很好，看起来就像一个完全正常运转的机场。完全是这样。仔细想想，安检，我的意思是，他直接走过安检，几乎就走到了登机口。是的。我的意思是，我没见过哪个安检离得这么近，但我的意思是，也许，你知道的，
maybe the Wilkesbury airport or whatever is just like that. But I would just believe there was another security thing off to the left and Pam didn't know until she got through security that he was ahead of her so close. That's all I'm going to say. She doesn't ever her shoes. She's like holding her shoes. She's gone through security clearly. I just chose to be okay with it.
威尔克斯伯里机场或者其他什么地方就是这样的。但我宁愿相信左边还有另一个安检口，而且帕姆直到通过安检才发现他就在她前面这么近的地方。这就是我要说的全部。她根本没有鞋子。她就像是拿着鞋子。她显然已经通过安检了。我只是选择接受它。
Yeah. I just needed this goodbye so desperately. Yeah. It didn't matter to me. And it's so beautifully framed. It's so beautiful and everything. So yeah. It's so silent, which is interesting because presumably Pam would have had her microphone
是的。我太渴望这场告别了。是的。对我来说这并不重要。而且它的构图太美了。太美了，一切都如此。所以，是的。它是无声的，这很有趣，因为按理说帕姆应该戴着麦克风
on even though Michael has taken his off. In the movie theater, you think she came, she was in King's Beach? Oh, she must have clicked off her mic because she didn't want anybody to know. That's a good call. That's a good call. I like that. Yeah. We often talk about, did our characters ever turn our mics off?
即使迈克尔已经摘下了他的。在电影院里，你觉得她来过，她去了金斯比奇？哦，她一定把麦克风关掉了，因为她不想让任何人听到。这倒是个好解释。这解释得通。我喜欢这个。是的。我们经常讨论，我们的角色有没有关掉过麦克风？
Like when we went to the bathroom, when we turned off our mic, like we would as actors. As actors, if you went to the bathroom or you went to your trailer, you'd like click your mic off. Yeah. So here's your question about doing this scene. I've told this story before. This was not scripted. There was nothing for us to say.
比如当我们去洗手间时，当我们关掉麦克风时，就像我们作为演员会做的那样。作为演员，如果你去洗手间或者去你的保姆车，你会把麦克风关掉。是的。所以这里是关于拍摄这场戏的疑问。我以前讲过这个故事。这不是剧本里写的。没有什么台词需要我们说。
And so Paul Feig just told me to run up and tell Steve Carell goodbye. Jenna to Steve. Have you ever said what you actually said or is that a mystery that you will? No. I've never really revealed exactly what I said to Steve, but you know, the gist of it was just what it had meant to me to work with him over these seven years. And I thanked him for a few personal things that he had done for me along the way. And we both cried and we hugged each other.
所以保罗·费格只是告诉我要跑过去跟史蒂夫·卡瑞尔说再见。珍娜对史蒂夫。你有没有说过你当时到底说了什么，还是说这是一个你将永远保守的秘密？没有。我从来没有真正透露过我对史蒂夫说了什么，但你知道的，大意就是这七年来和他合作对我的意义。我感谢了他一路上为我做的一些私人的事情。我们都哭了，我们拥抱了彼此。
And I've said this before. After that first take, we went back to Paul and he was like, okay, okay, that was amazing. That was so good. Could you do it a little faster? Because it was like, it was like four minutes. Right. I was just like told Tommy. Steve ever thought he'd ever had.
我以前也说过。在拍完第一个镜头后，我们回到保罗身边，他就像是，好的，好的，那太棒了。太好了。你们能稍微快一点吗？因为它就像是，就像四分钟。没错。我当时就像是在告诉汤米。史蒂夫曾经认为他经历过的。
Right. Because there's no other, there's no other camera. It's a water. It's a water. Yeah. He's like, we're just going to tighten it up a little. So then it got easier. We didn't do it very many times.
没错。因为没有别的，没有别的镜头。这是一个长镜头。这是一个长镜头。是的。他就像是，我们只是要把节奏稍微收紧一点。所以后来就变得简单了。我们没拍多少次。
It got easier. I needed the first one for me. Yeah. That was mine. Yeah. Well, so often you're trying to get emotion in a take and the first ones people are working out the, you know, the eye log or whatever. And then like two or three is where you really find your sweet spot.
变得容易了。对我来说，我需要第一条。是的。那是属于我的。是的。嗯，通常情况下，你试图在一个镜头中表现出情绪，而第一条时大家还在琢磨眼神交流什么的。然后第二或第三条才是你真正找到最佳状态的时候。
And then it starts to get kind of mannered and fake afterwards. And it's interesting that it was like, on this episode, everything was like at an 11 on take one. On the first take. Yeah. Bring it down a bit. Yeah. Well, then Pam has this talking head.
然后在这之后它就开始变得做作和虚假了。有趣的是，在这一集里，一切都在第一条时就直接拉到了11级。在第一个镜头。是的。把它稍微降下来一点。是的。嗯，然后帕姆有了这个单人访谈。
And I remember we did a lot of versions of this talking head, but I love the one that we picked. It was really, really sweet. Although I never felt like I nailed it. I never, I was so emotional from having shot the scene that I, I just couldn't, I don't know, I just, it was hard for me. This talking head. Well, I disagree.
我记得我们为这个单人访谈拍了许多版本，但我非常喜欢我们最后选定的那一个。真的非常非常温馨。虽然我觉得我从来没有完全掌控好它。我从没有，拍完那场戏后我的情绪太饱满以至于我，我只是办不到，我不知道，这对我来说太难了。这个单人访谈。嗯，我不同意。
I think you totally nailed it. Connected to the plane taking off that thing, right? Or is that just, is there a cut? That's after. Oh, thank goodness. Yeah. Can you imagine if we had to wait for the plane every time you got a take? No.
我觉得你完全驾驭了。与飞机起飞的那个画面相连，对吧？还是说那只是，中间剪辑过？那是之后的事。哦，谢天谢地。是的。你能想象如果每次你拍一条我们都得等飞机起飞吗？不。
No, but we did have to wait for that plane to take off so that we could do that and a plane never took off. We waited like an hour to get a shot of me watching a plane take off. Randy reminded me that a plane did eventually take off, but it was like a little private plane, which obviously Michael would not be on. So how'd we do that shot? We added it in post. I, a fakey plane.
不，但我们确实为了等那架飞机起飞以便拍摄那个画面而等了很久，结果飞机根本没起飞。我们等了一个小时才拍到我看着飞机起飞的镜头。兰迪提醒我，一架飞机最终确实起飞了，但那是一架小型的私人飞机，迈克尔显然不会坐那架飞机。那我们是怎么拍那个镜头的？我们在后期制作中加上去的。我，一架假飞机。
I just looked off at nothing. Another metaphor for him going up into the sky. See? Yes. It was an important shot. He starts in the sky and ends in the sky in this episode. One of the things I always love about our show is right after a big emotional moment, there's then usually this great comedic bit, sometimes dark.
我只是看着虚空。这是他飞向天空的另一个隐喻。看吧？是的。这是一个重要的镜头。他在这一集里从天空中开始，又在天空中结束。我一直喜欢我们节目的一大特色是，通常在大喜大悲的情感时刻过后，接着就是一个绝妙的喜剧包袱，有时甚至带点黑色幽默。
And this one, this one is a definite foreshadowing of how D'Angelo is going to be. There is the party. It's Michael's party. It's the next day. He hasn't shown up and there's a big cake and D'Angelo is like, well, we should just have a piece, right? He's, you know, might as well, but he digs in with his hand and he starts eating the cake and then he throws it in the trash.
而这一次，这绝对预示了德安吉洛将是怎样的一个人。那是派对。是迈克尔的派对。那是第二天。他还没出现，这里有一个大蛋糕，而德安吉洛却说，嗯，我们应该吃一块，对吧？他，你知道的，反正也得吃，但他直接用手去挖，开始吃蛋糕，然后又把它扔进了垃圾桶。
He's like, no, and then he goes back in and then he does it again and people are like, oh my goodness. Dwight turns to Jim and goes, oh no. I love that moment between Dwight and Jim at the end. It's like the devil you know, right? You're like, why did we ever wish we would want anyone other than Michael? Well, I guess Dwight never did, but. But also I love when Dwight and Jim team up and just to see like, oh, okay, it's going
他说，不，然后他又走回去，再次这样做，人们都惊呼，哦天哪。德怀特转向吉姆说，哦不。我太喜欢最后德怀特和吉姆之间的那个时刻了。这就像是你所熟知的恶魔，对吧？你会想，为什么我们曾经希望除了迈克尔之外还要别的任何人？嗯，我猜德怀特从来没有这么想过，但是。但我也很喜欢德怀特和吉姆联手，看到“哦，好吧，原来是这两个人对抗这个家伙”，这真是一个有趣的设定。
to be those two against this guy is an interesting thing. When you think about it, when you watch the show now on Peacock and there are no ads and you're just kind of watching it, that does feel like, oh, that's a weird place to end. But you have to remember that, you know, the show kind of ended and there was three minutes of commercials and this is like a little, a little bitty tag on the end. Yeah. That's true because you used to have to write for those act breaks and now it can be viewed without them.
仔细想想，当你现在在Peacock上观看这部剧，没有广告，只是连着看的时候，这确实会让人觉得，哦，这个结尾有点奇怪。但你必须记住，你知道的，这部剧原本播放时中间有三分钟的广告，而这只是结尾的一小段花絮。是的。确实如此，因为你过去必须为那些广告中断进行剧本创作，而现在它可以不用这些直接观看了。
Right. It does change the experience. It changes the pal a little bit because you're like, whoa, we're doing this now. They chose to end on the cake gag, strange. One thing I wanted to share was a lot of people in the cast who didn't have scenes on particular days, they all would just come back even on their day off to watch Steve's final scenes. And a lot of people obviously came back for this last day, crew and producers and writers and the cast all there to watch these final moments.
没错。这确实改变了观看体验。它稍微改变了一下节奏，因为你会觉得，哇，我们现在直接到这里了。他们选择以蛋糕的笑话作为结尾，这挺奇怪的。我想要分享的一点是，许多在特定日子里没有戏份的演员，甚至在他们的休息日也会赶回来观看史蒂夫的最后一场戏。显然有很多人为了这最后一天赶了回来，剧组工作人员、制片人、编剧和演员们都在那里观看这最后的时刻。
And then we had a party in the warehouse to say goodbye to Steve. It was so perfect. Do you remember Nancy made that cake or had a cake made? Yeah. And it was a giant cake in the shape of a world's best boss mug. Yeah. It was a huge coffee mug. Yes.
然后我们在仓库里举办了一个派对来向史蒂夫告别。太完美了。你还记得南茜做了那个蛋糕或者订做了一个蛋糕吗？对。那是一个巨大的蛋糕，做成了“世界最佳老板”马克杯的形状。对。那是一个巨大的咖啡马克杯。是的。
And John had made a tribute video. He had had a bunch of different people send in goodbye messages like you would have at a retirement party. Rain gave a speech on behalf of the cast. I gave a speech. I remember. You gave a speech. If I had known you guys were talking, I would have brought it.
约翰还制作了一个致敬视频。他找了许多不同的人发来告别信息，就像你在退休派对上看到的那样。雷恩代表全体演员发表了讲话。我发表了讲话。我记得。你发表了讲话。如果我早知道你们在聊这个，我就会把它带来了。
I think it's... Oh! My computer somewhere. Oh, that's so great. I remember there were a lot of jokes about how he could have been a dick, but he wasn't. Because he had all of the... He was so important to the show and I think I compared him to other leads who were in the news for bad behavior or something.
我觉得这……哦！我的电脑在某个地方。哦，那太棒了。我记得有很多关于他本来可以变得很混蛋但他并没有这么做的笑话。因为他拥有所有这些……他对这部剧太重要了，我想我把他与其他因为不良行为等原因登上新闻的主演进行了对比。
I can't remember the whole gist of it. Yeah. Oh, that's so sweet. A big thing that happened and this was Randy Cordray's idea was that we retired his number on the call sheet. It was our number one and moving forward, the call sheet started with number two forever. So it didn't matter whoever we were going to hire to ever be maybe the boss in the future. They were not going to get to be number one.
我不记得具体的大意了。是的。哦，太甜了。发生的一件大事——这是兰迪·科德雷的主意——就是我们在通告单上退役了他的编号。他是我们的头号（Number One），此后的通告单将永远从二号开始。所以无论我们以后要雇谁来当老板。他们都无法成为头号。
That belonged to Steve and we made him a Dunder Mifflin Hockey Jersey with his number one on it and the cast signed it. I remember Randy brought it around to all of us in our trailers and we all signed this and when Nancy was on the podcast, she shared that they had framed that and that's Steve's office. Yeah. It was really sweet. Well, we are at the end of this episode and before we wrap it up, I thought I would bring
那是属于史蒂夫的，我们为他定制了一件印有他的一号的邓德米夫林曲棍球球衣，所有演员都在上面签了名。我记得兰迪把它带到了我们每个人的保姆车里，我们都在上面签了名，当南茜上播客时，她分享说他们把那件球衣装裱起来挂在史蒂夫的办公室里了。是的。真的非常温馨。好吧，我们迎来了这一集的尾声，在结束之前，我想
out my last bit of digital clutter. Woohoo! Digital clutter. Yes. At this time, I would do little vignette videos for NBC.com and ventures with Angela, you guys, around the set and a lot of fans had written in and asked if I would do a goodbye video with Steve and NBC.com gave me a flip camera. Do you remember that?
亮出我最后一点数字杂物。呜呼！数字杂物。是的。当时，我会为NBC.com录制一些小短片，安吉拉，你们和我一起在片场闲逛，许多粉丝写信问我是否能和史蒂夫拍一个告别视频，于是NBC.com给了我一台小翻盖摄像机。你还记得吗？
Yeah. And I went and filmed it and I found it in my digital clutter and I thought we should hear a little bit of this final goodbye with Steve. Hi, Office fans. It's Angela Kinsey. I'm in my trailer and this is Steve's last week on our show and we've all been pretty emotional this week as Michael Scott leaves Dunder Mifflin and I have to say there were some tears at our table read and there were tears on set and it's just been just sort
记得。然后我去把它拍了下来，我在我的数字杂物里找到了它，我想我们应该听听这段与史蒂夫最后告别的一小部分。嗨，办公室的粉丝们。我是安吉拉·金西。我在我的保姆车里，这是史蒂夫在我们剧组的最后一周，随着迈克尔·斯科特离开邓德米夫林，这周我们所有人都相当情绪化，我必须说，我们在剧本围读时落泪了，我们在片场也落泪了，这只是，你知道的，非常美好的一周，我们既快乐又悲伤，五味杂陈，我只是想现在走到史蒂夫的保姆车那儿，也许我们大家可以一起说声再见。我们到了史蒂夫的保姆车前。嗨，史蒂夫。我是安吉拉。嘿。别害怕。我能进来吗？
of a very, you know, great week and we're happy and we're sad and we're all of it and I just thought I would walk over to Steve's trailer now and maybe we could all say goodbye. Here we are at Steve's trailer. Hi, Steve. It's Angela. Hey. Don't be afraid. Can I come in?
我们能说声再见吗？好吧。不是我个人，而是，你知道的，你的粉丝们。好吧。进来吧。好的。所以我只是想代表迈克尔·斯科特的粉丝们，也代表你所有的粉丝来到这里，当你，当你的角色离开
Can we say goodbye? Okay. Not me personally, but, you know, your fans. Okay. Come on in. Okay. So I just wanted to come here on behalf of all the fans of Michael Scott and of yours and is there anything you want to say to the fans as you, as your character departs
这部剧时，你有什么话想对粉丝们说吗？我还真有。我，我犯了一个巨大的错误。哦不。我想我大概不应该离开，而且你们会像完全失业一样。我只是，我真的非常感激。我想我们大家都很感激能拥有这些工作，这实际上不仅仅是一份工作，我想这里的每个人都有这种感受。
the show? I do, actually. I've, I've made an enormous mistake. Oh no. And I think that I probably shouldn't be going and you're gonna have like zero job. I'm just, I'm really thankful. I think we're all very thankful to have had the jobs and this is more than a job really and I think everybody here feels that way.
这不仅充满乐趣，而且我和我妻子聊过这件事，并且，过去几周我也一直挺情绪化的。她指出的其中一件事，好吧，我马上就出来。我在拍我的告别视频。我们马上就到。我想她说的其中一件事，我觉得真的切中要害，那就是这是一个在职业生涯中定义了我的角色，但除此之外，她说，这些人都是你的朋友。
It's been not only fun, but I was talking to my wife about it and, and I've been pretty emotional the last couple of weeks too. And one of the things she pointed out, yeah, okay, I'll be right out. I'm filming my farewell. We'll be right there. I think one of the things she said that I thought really hit the nail on the head was that it's a part that has kind of defined me professionally, but on top of that, she said, these are your friends.
所以对我来说，这，这对我来说，就是为什么这部剧对我如此重要，以及人们在我参演的这些年里观看它、喜爱它，并且将继续喜爱它的原因，因为它是一部过去是、将来也一直会是一部精彩绝伦的剧集。亚历克斯，你把收音杆拿低点。好的。来自《与安吉拉的冒险》。再见，史蒂夫。我们爱你。
So that to me, that, that to me is, is why the show has been so important to me and the fact that people have watched it and enjoyed it over these years that I've been on it and will continue to enjoy it because it remains and will continue to be a fantastic show. Alex, you passed a squinch down. Okay. From Adventures with Angela. Goodbye, Steve. We love you.
我们爱你，史蒂夫。啊。我最喜欢的部分是凯利·坎特利敲门的时候。是的。因为这太真实了。一下子把人拉回去了，对吧？是的。当时就是那种感觉。
We love you, Steve. Aww. My favorite part is when Kelly Cantley knocks on the door. Yeah. Because it goes so real. It takes back, right? Yeah. That's what it was like.
跟某人进行了一次走心的交谈，然后就会像这样，“五分钟后需要你”。好吧。好吧。我在这里正哭得撕心裂肺呢。这确实把你带回了过去，而且这真的很，关于这部剧在关系方面的独特性，你知道的，在同一个外景地与同一群剧组人员和演员共同度过七年、九年时间，这是多么独特，并且我认为这也是因为
Having like this heart to heart with someone and there'd be like this, need you in five minutes. Okay. Okay. I'm just crying my heart out in here. It does take you back and it was such a, he's so right about how unique that show is in terms of the relationships of being, you know, seven years, nine years on the same lot with the same crew and the same actors and, and I think also just the fact that it was
它是一部伪纪录片。我们在一起片场的时间非常多，而不是像其他剧那样（把时间）花在等待打光之类的事情上。这真是一次非常不寻常的体验。嗯，我喜欢史蒂夫所说的，你知道的，我想这就是他和南茜谈论过的，这部剧讲的是友谊。我认为这就是它的美妙之处，而且我们直到今天依然拥有这份友谊。我的意思是，这周，珍娜，我们和全体演员在一个群聊里发短信，我们一直在发短信
a mockumentary. We had so much time on set with each other as opposed to, you know, waiting for lighting and stuff. It was just a very unusual experience. Well, I loved that Steve said, you know, I guess it's what Nancy and him had talked about that the show was about friendship. And I think that's the beauty of it and that we still have that to this day. I mean, this week, Jenna, we were on a text thread with the whole cast and we were texting
来回交流。你不在那个群里。你不是演员阵容里的。毛线人被砍了。是的。如果你留下来，你就会在那个群里了。没错。嗯，格雷格，非常感谢你今天加入我们。
back and forth. You were not on that thread. You were not in the cast. Yarn Man was cut. Yes. If you had stayed in, you would have been on that thread. Exactly. Well, Greg, thank you so much for joining us today.
来回讨论。你当时不在那个主题里。你不在演员阵容中。毛线侠被删掉了。是的。如果你当时没退出来，你就会在这个主题里。没错。好吧，格雷g，非常感谢你今天加入我们。
This was such a treat. It's my pleasure. I love coming to do your show just to see you two guys and have fun chat. And if they didn't record it, that'd be fine with me. Aw. Greg, you're just the best. And you guys, thank you again for sending in your awesome questions. We loved them.
这真是一种享受。这是我的荣幸。我喜欢来做你们的节目，只是为了见见你们俩，开心地聊聊天。如果他们不录音，我也觉得没问题。哦。格雷格，你真是太棒了。各位，再次感谢你们发来这么棒的问题。我们太喜欢了。
And next week, we'll be back with Steve Carell. Steve Carell, see you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
下周我们将迎回史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我们到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔，制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾恩斯利·巴比科克。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。